what are my thoughts on shady email
marketing techniques on their share of
them today on this episode of ask Evan
so Risa got spain by company calls
indigo and I got an email saying that
hey you've got this gift card to go to
our store and the first thing I day was
scroll to the bottom and look for how I
can unsubscribe from the email list that
I never sent up for in the first place
and what was at the bottom angered me so
much this is what it read this email was
sent to my address this is a post only
mailing from zinda go please do not
attempt to apply to this message we
would love to hear from you this drives
me nuts first of all don't spam people
second of all why do you use a no reply
email where people can't then right back
to you right if I was actually
interested in this offer I would want to
be able to connect with you third don't
say that you love hearing from people
when you use a no reply email that you
don't want the you don't people to write
back to from right and it just drives me
nuts that these companies exist with the
sending this spam out and people are
still using no reply emails in this day
in age and at the end they're saying we
would love to hear from you and number
four whatever the email address is what
is it what's the email address the email
address is where is it where is it where
is it where is it where is it emails at
zinda go com blacklisted blacklist
emails at cigna go com that's my right
for the day so my question for you guys
today is what do you think about using
no reply emails leave in the comments
below do you use it for your business
please say you don't but I want to hear
from you leave it below and I'll see you
soon what are my thoughts on shady email
marketing techniques I'm going to share
them today no you show them today in
today's episode I'm going to show you
them what are my thoughts on shady email
marketing techniques I'm going to share
no I'm going to share my thoughts one of
my thoughts i'm going to show them to ok
what are my thoughts on shady email
marketing techniques i'm going to share
them today i'm going to show them to